c'est un budget de continuité qu'à
présenter bill morneau deuxième budget
du gouvernement libéral après avoir
annoncé vraiment l'essentiel de ses
mesures-phare l'an dernier cette année
c'est vraiment la continuité donc pas de
surprise pas de grande nouveauté dans ce
qui a été présenté un déficit de 28
milliards de dollars mais on a réduit de
moitié la réserve de prudence qui avait
été annoncée l'an dernier qui était de 6
milliards on ramènerait à 3 milliards
donc déficit de 28 milliards et on ne
voit pas toujours le moment où on va
revenir au déficit zéro à l'équilibré
budgétaire ce n'est toujours pas prévu
ce qui compte ce qui est très important
pour ce gouvernement c'est de ne pas
faire augmenter la dette par rapport à
l'ensemble de l'économie la dette qui va
demeurer autour de 31 pour cent du
produit intérieur brut
si vous attendiez des annonces sur les
infrastructures s'est remis à plus tard
la banque de l'infrastructure va prendre
forme à la fin de 2010 est jusqu'à
maintenant pour 2016-2017 l'argent qui
étaient prévus en infrastructure ce qui
a été mis en oeuvre
c'est seulement de 50 à 75% donc il ya
du retard dans les investissements
d'infrastructures on ne sait pas si par
exemple le gouvernement va investir et à
quelle hauteur dans le réseau électrique
métropolitain de montréal
innovation formation ce sont des mots
clés beaucoup d'argent en innovation
avec la création d'un guichet unique un
fonds pour l'innovation stratégique ont
investi dans les technologies propres
on veut créer des super g notamment pour
vraiment chercher davantage faire
davantage de recherches et trouver
davantage des emplois dans ce secteur de
l'innovation et améliorer donc la
formation parce que les temps changent
il ya d'automatisation au cours des
prochaines années donc on veut aider les
gens à se transformer donc on va
moderniser en quelque sorte la formation
dans le marché du travail
il ya des mesures qui touchent
l'ensemble du canada sauf le québec
parce qu'il ya vraiment des enveloppes à
part pour le québec on parle de la garde
des jeunes enfants et des prestations
parentales d'assurance emploi qui seront
disponibles maintenant sur 18 mois pour
les familles pour les congés de
maternité congé de paternité mais à 33 %
du revenu des familles en question de
très légères hausses de taxes sur
l'alcool et sur le tabac et la fin du
crédit
impôts pour le transport en commun vous
aviez droit à 15 % des sommes que vous
dépensez pour les laisser passer
eva à partir du 1er juillet ce sera
annulée ce n'est pas un budget qui va
passer à l'histoire c'est un budget de
continuité alors à l'an prochain